I don't know if you would wait for me if I went to jail for 20
years and I'm like what why are you going to jail and he's like
it's just I mean hypothetically I'm like what do you mean why
would you think that like if I had to hide a body would you hide
it with you like what are you talking about like what who comes
up with these hypotheticals
things are totally fine things are totally normal things are
totally cool everything's fine everything's fine everything's
fine guys it's all good nothing bad's happening we're all okay
what is this abomination
It's not okay like what he's speaking of
I don't know enough about DDG I don't know bullish
Fortnite
Nick POV we're Nick right now Nick POV
Is she doing that or
You want to just lay down so we can see you or something Like
a Amouranth doing yoga with this guy getting the people's elbow
treatment okay okay you love to see it she's getting more sensual
I'm going to skip Okay am I dude I don't know how Olive Garden
is in the states Olive Garden in Canada is literally the worst
food that exists it's like the worst food that exists Sticks
oops The only time you get Olive Garden is oh Italian kitchen
no no no it's just Italian kitchen I thought it was something
special
Dude the the only time you get Olive Garden ever Is if you have
like a tradition around it and you like I think if you have a
tradition around it and there's like some memory there it's like
a memory thing
They wanted a lot of food
All ladles
Dude what the
got the sticks here too Why do they have why do they have ice
cream pails of pasta sauce from Olive Garden dude Oh Oh will
she chew that's a great question
We've got the perfect food to see if Amouranth's updated her
programming is she on version 2.0 No not really Wow
Date night
Because
Might as well make money while you're making co- Bro they put
chicken gnocchi in a bucket they did I just never really cared
if people were there or not like if I could view a number and
never Their style like puts me off so badly this is so gaudy
Who likes stuff like this who likes like crazy gaudy [__]
It's my enjoyment and whatever I'm more of just enjoying doing
a thing if I it's It's like Trump style Enjoyable So judgy I
am judgy I'm a judgy [__] Not really I don't really
care about the scale
Yeah it's not the only thing micro
The energy is too what Like you become you wonder if it becomes
what No no she did not just say hold on what did she just say
hold on what did she just say
The energy is too what Like you become you wonder if it becomes
what
Yeah I heard micro but I did okay the the thing is not funny
I thought she was talking about my I thought she was about to
microwave that concoction and I was going to have like a conniption
okay if she microwaved the breadsticks in there that plate
Yeah it's not the only thing micro Oh she was definitely calling
you micro Oof streaming right now is really fun but I have a
pretty micro audience oof oof The energy is too what Oh the energy
yes the energy oh my god Like you become you wonder if it becomes
what
I don't know I think as long as you're doing something fun it
can be fun it's only not fun when you're doing something you
don't really want to do for the sake of a trend You know who
would be really funny it would be so funny if I could get Lycan
on stream right now to review the gnocchi what do you think of
this chicken gnocchi in an ice cream bucket here Lycan what do
you think about it
Wait it is gnocchi isn't it I thought you say gnocchi don't you
say gnocchi you say it funny I say everything funny It is average
like 7 inches average so the energy is micro which is more important
than the energy What happened to Lycan I assume he's living happily
somewhere her camera's up during the food review ASMR hold on
turn it up Amouranth's made her glorious ASMR return Wow only
two I'm actually impressed Gnocchi gnocchi dude really or this
is where we're timing out
Come on man come on man come on man come on man come on man oh
and the the chat's running perfectly so like you know it's
Aw dude she's going to be done eating by
OH NEVER MIND OH SHE'S CHEWING
This is hold on you guys ready are you guys ready hold on I need
to go get a drink I need to go get a drink I'm actually pausing
I'm just leaving you guys with dead air for 2 seconds
I only very rarely do that Just walk away entirely leave you
guys with dead air but I needed I needed some actual
whiskey okay I went and got some actual whiskey okay It's this
is going to be I need to make sure I'm inebriated okay I hope
that's insecure from the bread NO WAIT I MUTED I muted I muted
no no
no Okay hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on I made
so many funny jokes and you guys weren't laughing I just said
okay just think about it this is what XQC
was saved from when he went to an Italian restaurant with Amouranth
okay He was saved from horrors beyond human comprehension thank
god Nick showed up to pull her out of the restaurant okay XQC
was going to bear witness to some terrifying things bro that
breadstick just fell all in the bowl
bro I I bet you she could have sold you know 3 years ago she
could have sold this $50 a pop PPV $50 a pop PPV on only fans
okay watching her eat these phallic breadsticks with a white
like The white creamy sauce falling off okay this is what a millionaire
looks like chat What are you printing Legal documents What
She's looking rough I mean okay hold on I want to put this in
perspective when people say she's looking rough I have to now
I have to be a soy for like 2 seconds okay she's like 2 months
away or a month away from like some pretty intense trauma okay
her husband is like clearly abusive there's like a lot of bad
things going on here okay I feel like I understand why she's
still like I Feel like given all of this though she still close
her mouth while she chews At
I can't show you these man dude
What the She's like literally she's literally like out of it
I knew it I called it What the Yeah what's happening here what
the is happening here dude like she got on we see Dude this is
not THIS IS
PASTA sauce this is just like saliva she is like she's literally
like slobbering right now
That's not pasta sauce she's eating like the most coom like food
possible just Okay maybe it is pasta sauce Cuz he wasn't yet
sleeping with me yet and he's not sleeping with me now It's a
black IT IS A BLACK MIRROR episode It is
No it's just trust information for the gun trust that we have
I put all our guns in a trust Just for legal protection And other
All these forms Imagine she just like kicks this bowl back she
put two hands to bowl throws the spoon away and just glug glug
glug glug and just sucks back all of the Alfredo whatever white
sauce is in here I'm just reprinting everything because I used
to have all these print one time in a folder But then I guess
I'm an idiot And I lost it I don't believe I lost it I'm pretty
sure someone stuffed it in a drawer somewhere and one day I'm
going to find it and be like god damn it
I didn't realize oh no
It's not very tasty you don't really care about that though smoking
cigars and Adderall both contribute to nasty About it all that
often and I eat a lot of them Cigar still What's up you watching
Amouranth eating stream with me right now Yeah Yeah It's it's
pretty foul I'm not going to lie Awesome She uh She looks a little
drugged out it's it's kind of weird I I feel I literally had
to just do a PSA on like why Like okay she's kind of like abused
and like she just went through some trauma and so we're laughing
but you know You know I know you think I know chat is made think
that battered women are actually most attractive type of women
but that that that's often not true in practice it's It's time
you guys start learning that don't act like you don't eat like
this by yourself
by myself with the camera off okay
Yeah there's a big difference Uh hold on let me play Girl are
you cold Am I still on Twitch yes I am Yeah pretty cold Really
Yeah it's cold the soup isn't helping I was cold before the soup
Whatever The eye contact is wild What's the plan for
Uh what do you mean Um
Just in general cuz our day is clear cuz we're going to Survive
I don't know Are you doing Friday Friday today did you work out
I will say she's chewing at least this time okay she is I can
see the jaw working
We're not just swallowing all of this whole Why does that matter
Because that's the rule What's the rule again I forgot Three
workouts Or I don't get to go horse riding Yes Interesting
What You're still enforcing that one huh Why not It's a good
for both of us like what's your downside How is it good for you
you don't even have to work out with me in this clause Well I
sometimes do Mostly you don't We'll change that soon Soon I mean
ideally Not immediately So you can do this for me as a favor.
Tell me as soon as you know you're going to work out that day
or the next day or
Why do I have to tell you a day ahead to work out? don't have
to. This is like when we have to schedule stuff on the calendar.
You don't have to. It's just it makes it easier She's getting
like more aggressive about it. She also made a joke about it
multiple times and how he's insecure about her breadsticks. I
need to clear my schedule to Why are you so inefficient at just
managing your own workout schedule? No, no, I'm I'm not I do
have my own. I'm just saying that if you want me to work out
with you, tell me before you do yours so that I can clear my
schedule and be alone. That's crazy. Why is that crazy?
I don't need you to work out with me. You should just work out
anyways. I know that. That's what I plan on doing. That's fine.
Currently, that's what I do because our things don't sync. But
you
Don't complain about something you don't want to fix, man. I
do want to fix it. I don't want to have to work out at all to
go horse riding. Why not? Because I should be able to work out
when I want to work out and horse ride when I want to horse ride.
Seriously? Yeah. Seriously. It's okay, baby, though. I'll do
it for you. I'll stick to it for you so you have some semblance
of a schedule and know that your wife is definitely going to
stay fit for her social media
It's okay.
I will do it. I will take one This is so insanely passive-aggressive.
Jesus. for the team. Yeah, now do all that without having to
enunciate it like that. Okay.
All right, again without the lip, sweetheart. You know, two can
play that game. You want me to just slop it out? Yes. What does
that mean? I could be like, well, why do I bother filing this
on time? already. Awesome. What's that? It's a spiraling already.
Awesome. Yeah, they they haven't been streaming together for
10 hours either. She's been like solo for 9 hours. She just came
in like grabbed food and they This is the first time they're
talking from my quick scan through. Although they actually talked
off They might have talked off stream earlier. She like paused
the game and [__] but Why do I bother looking up
this investment thing? Because taxes affect both of us. Look
at that. What do you mean? The investments affect both of us.
So are you making Are you making a claim that things that affect
both of us are the only things that need to be upheld? Cuz I
don't think that's how it works. Um I don't I don't know. It's
fine. Whatever. I'm sorry I said anything. We had I was just
kidding. It's fine. We said we're going to do it, so unless we
have a discussion about not doing it, you know. This is the stuff
that confuses me. This is not taking anything away from you.
It's pushing you to do the things you want to do and the things
that are just good for you. You're right. I'm sorry. I was kidding
and I'm I apologize. Are you okay? Yeah, I'm good. Just checking.
Checking. Are your shoulders still Huh?
Even though I don't really need it, I'm just like kind of confused
at why. God. Last I saw it was in the horse. Anyway, I got run
you. Now that I just got a new
You got any You got any clonazepam experts in the chat? Cuz that's
my best guess right now. I feel like this is uh This is very
interesting. Little zonked. I need to get a new What? I I lost
my badge last time, right? Uh
I don't I don't remember. Can I see if I can figure out this?
Probably both. It's usually both. I got a politics joke. A politics
joke? What is What is your politics joke?
Ain't no one going to say these Trump tariffs don't work. They're
even making poop in America now. That's You're a bit You're like
a week or two too late for that joke. I know.
I'm not that uh politically connected on Twitter. Yeah. I get
the jokes late. No, that's It's a good joke, though, man. I love
that joke. Right? They're even making poop in America now. Yep.
Dude, you want to hear the craziest thing? Tell me. This kid
actually Hold on. Wait, this could actually be a bit that works
for them with Amaranth just clowning. I don't He doesn't have
the security required for it, but him just like sitting here
being an and then Amaranth like clowning on him the whole time,
that could actually work. But it it will never last. He worked
in finance before. My god, that's crazy. What are the odds? to
like the most frat boy school in the world, Villanova. If he
can be a pope, you can be a pope. Would you want that? I don't
give a [__] I'm not Catholic.
You realize Wait. Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Priests are not allowed to have sex. I'm assuming you have to
be a priest to become a cardinal.
I mean, we don't have sex anyway, so it's not much of a difference.
You just get more clout. Listen, I'm just not that attracted
to little boys, okay? I could That might be not being That might
be the funniest comeback he's had, but it he married one, okay?
And then he turned her into a woman. It's very very strange behavior.
Like little boys? That's not a good But
cuz there's like Is this guy really not He doesn't. Anyways,
but he does not do the He was a finance guy, which is weird cuz
Oh, the pope. I thought you meant you. Yeah, the pope was a finance
guy. Like he was a finance guy in Chicago. Like I just can't
imagine like a frat boy one Dude, could you imagine like you're
at your whatever your college reunion and everyone's like, "What
happened to Rob?" Oh, didn't you hear? He's the pope now. How
to one-up everyone. That's wild. His Holiness. Oh, this guy is
so annoying, man. Goals. It's so weird because like it just shows
you that power is the ultimate currency because that's all the
pope needs. This Okay.
hold on. Riot donated three critical meme.
The uh uh Discord Send it on Discord. But um Dude, she's like
actually seething at the camera now. This would actually work,
okay? This actually works so well as a dynamic with him as the
super annoying loser and she's just like off the whole time.
If it won't It can't last, but I'll enjoy it while it happens,
okay? It's not really I mean, I'm sure you have access to the
Vatican's money, but can't really like just blitz it, you know?
What do you mean? I mean, the pope, you know, probably can spend
some amount of money, but he can't buy like crazy fancy [__]
Yeah, you can buy
maybe. without raising eyebrows. But this is a finance bro we're
talking about, so I'm sure there are loopholes. There are always
loopholes. I'm tired of what I need. I'm ready to take Vyvanse.
And my voice is recovering.
Bro, how How are you 10 hours into streaming you're like, "I'm
ready to take Vyvanse." What is happening? What are we doing?
Hold on. What is this? All these forms. Imagine she just like
kicks this bowl back. She put two hands on bowl, throws the spoon
away, and just
Okay, I Yeah, I got it. I got it. I got it. Is this Is this guy
okay? This is guy's probably I get it. I think it'd be funny.
I'm going off Vyvanse cold turkey so that your fans can't say
I'm a crack addict anymore. Yep. Yeah, of course y'all think
I'm annoying stupid
It's the simps that think so. Oh, it's so true.
It's so true. Right. He's actually fulfilling his role really
well right now. Yep. The The thing that unlocks this working
is Amaranth no longer like having to pretend to respect him and
just mocking him like quietly in the background. That's what
makes it work. If she's like slowly being beaten to compliance
and having to act like he's really cool the whole time, it sucks.
It's awful, but if she can sit here and just like mock him softly
the whole time, it would be really funny. Go ahead. Self-report.
I don't know what the [__] y'all guys gripe about
like Scroll down. I can't see chat. Yeah, exactly, Puff Shake.
You're still simp if you're a girl. How? If If they think I'm
annoying, that's simping. I thought simping was when you were
not the simps that think he's annoying. It's your definition
of simp. They think he's okay. I see. Yep. All right, like they're
saying that I don't know. I don't want to really get into it,
honestly. It's a can of worms. Got you. Well, probably wise.
You don't want to upset another community. We only have so few
left who will watch us. Bro, you're already at higher viewership
because there's the preponderance of uh drama, right? Like we
were at 600, 700. You know? I honestly I'm telling you this,
okay? At anything under 2,000 viewers, you don't have to worry
about off your fans. Mm. Because they're especially like in your
case, right? Because you've been around so long, like the people
who know you and like you know you like They do actually Hold
on. They are actually starting to get like people
Like we got kickbot.
Hold on. That didn't work. Wait, is my There's no way my keyboard's
dead right now. Never mind. You're going to grow way bigger.
Hey, one second. I need to find a thing that char Start charging
my keyboard. One second. That's when public perception and community
becomes like a huge thing. Now, it's different if you're small
and starting because then obviously right from the get-go it
matters, right? But if you're big coming back and everyone's
already So if you have 30 viewers, it matters. If you have 1,000,
it doesn't. And if you go to 2,000, it matters again is what
you're saying? More or less. Got it. There's some good advice,
chat, if you're trying to start a stream to keep in mind. Hey.
Well, another thing is that e-girls have it the hardest not to
grow community, but e-girls have it the hardest because like
Dude, what's up? I'm telling you, it works so well when she's
just like laughing at him cuz he's a the whole time. I was laughing
at the word hardest. E-girls have it the hardest. Like, yeah,
they do. Your chat's actually fast now. Yeah, it is I show up
and I we gain 200 viewers? Great. We should just mute and pretend
we're yelling at each other. I don't have to pretend with us.
I'll just be like, "Mute it." It's so genuine. Yeah. Dude, okay.
I challenge y'all to say this. "Where am I abusive?" Go for it.
Go for it. Oh my god, no.
Dude, but for real, though, like actually look at their stats.
This chatters by day. They would get like the same number or
fewer chatters than me with like way like like three, four times
the viewers, right? Cuz they're viewbotting. And they actually
had a couple days where they're They're like a lot of actual
chat activity. Now, it's down again today, but it'll pick up
if the both of them are fighting. Kill for it. How am I abusive?
Name one thing. Don't let them lie to you. my stream is on on
a going live soon, right? Which I will go live at some point
today. Don't let them lie to you, king. Ignore the haters. Look
at the VOD. We'll pick something then. What's abusive? I feel
like at no point did I go above your energy. When you started
talking about how she's infertile, how she's barren, how she's
like a hag nobody could possibly love. I think that's probably
around the on that part. You know, I accept it. No, maybe after
we bed if you want to count like duration of energy. But Well,
sure. Sure. But like I don't think at any point like I was like
way above
you know, where you were at. Controlling. Listen, guys. I use
this analogy a lot. Yeah, the gate code was insane. That that
was insane. The cheating thing was insane. There's one more.
Oh, the I'm going to lock you up because you think you're like
a biblical character. All of those things using those out of
context are like pretty on a crew team, a rowing team, obviously
you would want to talk to the guy behind you to determine what
it is y'all are trying to do. Are y'all just going for some light
exercise? Are you trying to win the race? You know? Or are you
just enjoying the view, right? It would be if one guy thought
the goal is to go fast and win the race or set a lap record and
the other guy was like, "I'm on a scenic view." But that's why
it's important to communicate, right? And obviously like let's
say both guys are committed to hitting a, you know, record time
and then halfway through the the thing one guy says, "You know
what? I don't want to do it anymore." That's still better to
tell your partner than to not. Can you use an eye watering Sure.
if you can find an extra strength one? Sure.
Ask him for that because you wanted him to go away? One, two.
Two. Can I get some water, too, please? You need water to drink?
Yeah. Yeah. Dude, the eye watering is the eye watering is like
a little much. It looks like she's about to like cry while laughing
about it. It actually doesn't matter if you want to take the
scenic route. It's a huge sense of looming dread over all OF
THIS. THERE KIND of is. I'm actually Yo, okay, for the first
time ever kind of agreeing with you a little There is like a
weird feeling of him
Dude, how crazy is it? I didn't even cover much of that, but
how crazy is it that basically the argument people use to prove
that Hassan's anti-Semitic that saying Zionist when 80% of believe
in some form of Zionism? argument they use to call other people
anti-Semitic. Yeah. I I I'm so confused.
If you want to go as fast as you can, the important thing is
that both people are in sync cuz it feels bad when a person's
not. You know what I mean? Oh, are these each 500 or are they
together
They are each 500. Oh, I'll do one then. Sure. Lonely Lex just
tipped $2. I don't know how I long for a female companion that
would eat bucket slop by my side, no chewing required. My dear
Caitlyn, run raptured and pray for me. Uh thank you. Thank you
for the donation, Mr. Friedman. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Like me coming Dude, I watched I watched Destiny talking about
his court stuff tonight. I don't I literally I feel like he's
like actually losing it. Like he's just like his lawyers must
have told him that it's like definitely going to trial now and
they don't know how it'll go and he's like started coming up
with the conspiracies.
It's actually like like storm's coming, okay? Storm's coming.
Trust the plan level [__] It's I don't know. It's
wild.
Dude, I Storm's coming. It Q is Q is telling us. It is, yeah.
JFK Jr. is going to show up at Destiny's trial and exonerate
him, okay? 100%. It's brought your [__] Dr. Phil
just tipped $1. I miss this so much. Dr. Phil just tipped $1.
I miss this so much.
I'm glad we can entertain Dr. Phil. Is she not going to finish
her slop? What the [__] Yeah, I mean like what's
happening here is like the people who are haters, they don't
understand
I mean they probably have never been in a longer term relationship,
A. Which makes sense if they're younger. Yeah. But like Okay,
there's nobody under 25 watching Amouranth's stream.
There's nobody under I feel like there might not be anybody under
30 watching Amouranth's stream, to tell you the truth. I feel
like the people who watch this are the same people who watch
like Desperate Housewives stuff and me. But other than that,
yeah, same people watch Desperate Housewives stuff. It's just
like watching it's just drama, right? That's what it is. I don't
really want to litigate the children. I feel that 100%. You mean
zoomers don't like this? Okay, so one is a naughty fox. Match,
okay? What a naughty fox.
I can't read it but I left my phone over there. The other one
is a guy. What a naughty fox. Hold on. Let's see him. I don't
see him. I I have to read the other one. I'm just surprised there's
only two, to be honest. I expected way more [__]
talkers in your messages. A little bit disappointed, actually.
Why would you expect more [__] talkers? Because you
like you said, you pick up the simps. Yeah, but the best thing
that could happen is they come here and they spam the chat. That's
true. Being your message would be a waste. It's true. So, yeah.
I have a red pill job lined up. Do you care?
Well, hold on. Like if if I become a
like they bring me on occasionally. You come for somebody or
what kind of contributor? It's I I contribute her. I will become
a compiler.
Just saw a black Irish Nick is a thing.
Hold on. 10 hours 14 10 hours 14. Ooh, lucky I caught that. 10
hours 14 is where we were at. your energy? That's what happens
on Kick if you go over the um whatever the time that the time
there. Uh we we loaded when it was 10 hours 14
and it it like pauses automatically. It doesn't actually do like
dynamic
You go backwards, you can't go forwards. Like if if I become
a contributor
they bring me on occasionally.
You come for somebody
or what kind of contributor? It's I contribute her. I will become
a compiler,
okay? A compiler.
Is that okay? For what? I get to be a calling guest on a red
pill podcast. Is it Pearl's podcast? Yes. I thought you were
already a guest yesterday. Like a returning
like like the other guy that was in the call. Dr. Phil just tipped
$1.
Oops. No, don't go. Pearl will take anyone. That's crazy. Bro,
there's no way there's no way Pearl invited him back. What? Yeah.
He's coming in as a returning guest like a second second chair
or Oh my god. Dr. Phil just tipped $1.
No, don't go.
I think it's pretty obvious why I'd I I'd prefer that you don't,
but at the end of the day if you really want it, you do you,
king.
Really? It sounds like you really wanted that case. Well, it's
just a good opportunity.
For what? Is it? If I if I'm going to do streaming stuff or talk
a bunch. I mean [__] yeah. I thought we were going
to be done after the Kick contract, but if you still want to
be a big streamer, you know, I can't stop you there. I don't
even know if you'll be done. I feel like I'm going to I'll ask
you about a week out. Okay.
So, you won't have to respond to them until like a week out,
too?
Well, what does that have to do with anything? Oh, I just thought
you were saying it depends on whether I actually want to do streaming
or not. Well, and so if you're going to ask me a week out if
I want to do streaming or not, I thought you would wait for this
So, we can have this conversation off stream if you want, but
I'm also okay having it on
And it's just basically I think she's up on stream. Do you actually
mind if you quit streaming and I start streaming? But this whole
thing was like you said we fight because of the stream. Yeah,
but not because of my stream cuz I don't stream. Just cuz we're
working and we're No, we fight we fight because of your stream.
But if I streamed
it would be fine. I would mute it if we're going to fight, obviously.
No, it's different. It's 100% different. Oh, it's different.
I see. Well, think about it. Let's use the analog.
When our relationship began, I was working full-time. You were
working Wait, what the [__] I just heard the Discord
disconnect sound, but that wasn't you. [__] was that?
It's on their end. Time you're starting something. Weird. Right?
Okay, so So, we didn't really fight back then because I was so
you know. Yeah, but then if I quit, you're away from the house.
If I have to hear you just like pander to incels and red pills,
then it's going to become annoying. Would it be annoying when
you if you I'm telling you it would be annoying. I'm saying in
the event that you quit, you're going to be having a ton of fun.
Why would it be annoying? Like are you even going to be here?
you mean? If I'm having a ton of fun, so you'll let me do whatever
I want? I can go anywhere I want whenever I want? I mean, look.
Within to work out three times a week to go see my horses? Within
a relationship boundaries, sure. So, I don't have to work out
three times a week to see my horses if you're streaming? If if
you're not caring about social media anymore, I don't really
care how often or whether you work out. a yes or no? That is
Dr. Phil just tipped $1.
How about instead of working out multiple times to she ride horses,
we just don't feed her all of Garden's slop multiple nights a
week. We thought about that? I want you take some of that money,
you hire a [__] chef or something. Jesus. come up
with that yourself? Dr. Phil just tipped $1. Wow, did you come
up with that yourself? It's kind of content that doesn't involve
work out. Maybe it's not ego related. That's up to you, I guess.
But like what how do you define ego related? How do you define
I just mean like You called it. It's falling apart because they're
spending time together. Many such cases, okay?
Absence makes the heart grow fonder, okay? You around somebody
too much, it'll it'll probably almost always go No, my main content
is animal stuff on the stream. I would say that if it's no OnlyFans
or adult time no station, then then sure. That's how I'd say
it. We have AI now, though. Who cares about like, you know, OnlyFans
and AI? So, is your plan to let yourself go? I don't understand.
No, I just don't want a requirement to not work out.
You know, I'll just tell you that Discord is just trolling me.
[__] that. person to become very unhappy is to eliminate
all of the rigor from their life, okay? The the struggle is what
kind of keeps us, you know, bound to some semblance of reality.
Doesn't matter what the struggle What if I did let myself go,
would you stay with me? What if I did what you did and got fat?
What if you're being a big streamer? Hey, I got fat for a very
specific reason. So, if because my stream blew up I get fat because
my hormones aren't what they used to be? It's a very specific
reason. What what Why is that the the specific reason? That's
cuz I'm I'm getting older, right? I'm over the hill. I'm cooked.
But I'm still loyal to you. What would happen if I get fat? I
don't want to do any more yoga with pet caring. No, we're going.
Um so if it was a uh hormone Dude, of course he has to reference
the yoga bit. I knew he'd be [__] off. She had some
dude who's like doing yoga [__] on her. Hold on.
Let me Let me open this up. Don't be screaming. Don't be screaming.
Don't be screaming and go talk. Where's the show? Where's the
show? Yeah, this guy was in here working on her back and [__]
okay? It's like we're Nick right now actively. We're literally
Nick right now. Yeah, I'm I'm in the back. Dude, it's so Wait,
hold on. Did you see the xQc bit? Did you see it? Did anybody
link you the xQc thing? Oh, I think I got to show QTCinderella
xQc thing, okay? We have to watch it. We have to watch it. In
case you guys didn't see it earlier tonight, it was very early
in the stream, okay?
Where is xQc telling a story about Amouranth? It would have to
be really recent. Hold on. Uh-uh-uh-uh.
7 minutes. It was 7 minutes. Oh, was it really that long ago?
No. Reacts to this. When the police hunt her husband.
Am I missing it? Oh, right here. Yes, thank you. This one. They
made it in public chat. xQc reveals the time he went on a date
with Amouranth and her husband pulled up out of nowhere. I I
guess I never ever leak like private stories chat, but that was
like it was a whatever chat at this point it's it's whatever.
I don't I don't I don't think you would mind you would mind.
Hold on. Chat, I hope I don't I I hope I don't undo the little
bit of story so that it's going to hard to understand, okay?
Okay. Okay, way back when, okay? Um I think I was in
Right? And and Amouranth was in the area because of I think it
was like her birthday party or something like that or whatever
I went to the party. And then and I I'm like Wait, do you guys
remember that stream? That stream was awesome. Amouranth was
clearly into xQc and xQc was into like literally dancing like
a like a monkey for the camera. xQc felt bad that like the camera
wasn't being taken care of and he just sat there like doing memes
and bits for the camera the whole time. It was very funny and
Amouranth clearly wanted to talk to him and he was like, "Nah,
I'm taking care of chat right now." Like, "Oh, yo, um want to
get dinner or whatever, right?" So, let me say we'll just do
something Guys Guys, I go to dinner with friends all the time,
okay? It's not Guys, I At the time I used to go to dinner all
the time, right? And then um we end up, you know,
uh at setting up to go to dinner. So,
I don't know if she chose the place or I did. I think I think
I did. So, I got on Google and I look at places or whatever.
I'm like, "Oh, this place looks really fancy and nice or whatever."
I'm like, "Oh, let's go over there. It's lunchtime." And then
we get there and I got to be honest with you, the food chat is
it's chat it is so bad. I swear
I think everybody because okay, so I thought it was going to
be just me and her, right? So, I was like it's going to be cool.
It's going to be like a one-on-one dinner, you know? It's going
to be kind of a cool dinner. Good talk and share share interest
or or hobbies and you know You know what I'm saying, chat? So,
I thought He was very interested in Amouranth's hobbies, okay?
Wanted to know, Amouranth, how do you chew pasta without chewing
pasta? How do you consume pasta with never chewing? What other
hobbies do you have? One-on-one dinner. Right? So, I'm going
to I I was nervous to do that. I was nervous a little bit. I
was nervous to talk to them. So, I show up to this place, okay?
It's like some Italian place and I get there and it's this long
table It's not like a small table. It's like a long ass table.
And I sit down and it's me uh against the window and in front
of me it's uh Amouranth then uh I think I I think assistant,
manager, somebody else. And it's like it looks like a board meeting,
okay? It's all good. I wasn't mad about it, okay? I'm not getting
mad now. I'm not I'm not upset about it. Now it's just going
to
Bro, it it was just like a board
So, it's just me and then like four people. I'm like, "Ah, by
the squad I see." And I started having an interview with them
and just kind of talking to everybody, you know? Hey, it gets
I promise it gets better, okay? It gets better. is actually it
is chat I don't think anybody ate any of their like full like
full meal or whatever. It was just like we're just eating like
a whatever comes free with it like like like breadsticks or something
like that cuz it's so disgusting. It's just disgusting. Dude,
they might have actually gone to Olive Garden. Chat, I swear
chat this is a real story. I know this will sound crazy, but
guys I have never felt like I was more in a movie ever than that
one time, okay? So, we're just you know we're just chilling or
whatever and then then then nothing is happening. It's kind of
a slow It's kind of a slow night. It's like just chilling. And
I got to be honest with you, the convo wasn't really flowing.
It's kind of really It's more like a oh, anyway, so what do you
guys like um what do you guys like do for Amouranth or whatever?
Anyway, so now we're like and now and now we're in. And then
the place is the place is pretty like There's not a lot not a
lot of people, okay? It's getting It's getting really late. And
then I swear on everything door opens, a guy rolls in in a disguise
in a disguise,
okay? And I get to the table. Pulls the chair. Do you think Do
you think he actually had a disguise on or do you think xQc just
interprets his normal fashion day-to-day fashion as a disguise?
And he sits down, okay, wearing like this weird like hat and
like messenger bag like almost like a almost like a It literally
is just his normal style. And he's like, "Guys, I'm recording."
I'm like, "What the I swear chat my blood froze. I thought I
I thought I was about to get killed. I chat Hello, chat. Guys,
I genuinely thought I I was it was done for. It was GG, okay?
And it was just um
It was just It was just It was just her husband. It was just
showing up and I guess I guess he has maybe uh her texts or her
phone or her location or whatever. And the guy just pulled up
FROM OUT OF NOWHERE.
YEAH, he did talk. He did talk. He said He said, "Guys, I'm I'm
not going to I'm not going to dramatize the story and then say
something he didn't say. But I know for a fact I know for a I
know for a fact he said it. Guys, I'm recording." And then he
started he started arguing with her. And then he started to talking
like, "Oh, you you're just going to leave me at home to do this
and this task and this task and you're going to go out to dinner
or whatever." And then and they went and and and they went outside
to argue or whatever. And it's why I think this is this is real
cuz they they were arguing for like a long time. And I was it
was just me and her two of the assistants or whatever just like
that when they were outside across the street and you can There's
It's a BIG WINDOW. BIG ASS WINDOW. You can see them arguing and
we're just yep yep. And I started I started playing games on
my phone, okay? I'm playing I'm playing games on my phone. And
then I look around. I look every table that they have in in the
in the restaurant has the chairs
upside on the tables. THEY'VE BEEN CLOSED FOR AN HOUR. BRO, THE
RESTAURANT'S BEEN CLOSED THE WHOLE TIME. LIKE BRO, the guy's
like There's only like the owner left there counting the money
or whatever. There's like six seven rooms involved. None of them
are socialized properly. They're just sitting in this restaurant
like way past close waiting for Amouranth and her husband to
stop fighting. And they let us down. [__] And it's
like and then the guy's like, "Yo, guys, um you know, don't worry.
Like um you don't have to rush, but I mean we've been closed
or whatever." And I'm
I mean should I go or like um and then they're like, "Yeah, I
think I think you should go." And then and then I went home.
But chat, isn't that kind of chat isn't that kind of crazy? It's
pretty crazy story, no? Dude, chat I wish you could I wish you
could you could you could Like [__] that. Oh, we're
closed. Oh, should I like go? Should I go? Should I leave? Green
thoughts like what? Dude, the best part is is the way they're
describing like all of the [__] chairs flipped up
and that's when he noticed like, "Oh, maybe I shouldn't be here."
Like there would have been people cleaning, would have been vacuums
running. When you close up a restaurant, you clean up before
you go home. And then he just apparently waited until the very
end. And then the owner is the only person left. And he's like,
"Oh, My POV. Like it's like lights were kind of dim. Just kind
of like nervous at a dinner. And and dude, it's just the way
he did it, chat. Like I did it at the table,
Like chat I'm doing like this, right? Like this is I'm sitting
over here. This is the table. And guy that's like this does this.
Like that. LIKE RIGHT NEXT TO ME. LIKE DUDE, I
I THOUGHT HE WAS HE WAS GOING TO PULL A GUN. BUT OKAY, BUT that's
that's just me being dramatic, okay? Cuz I'm always I'm always
on edge, but yeah. Anyway, Nick really does have like an Elliot
Rodger aura about him, doesn't he? I feel like I feel like he
could do it. Nick could definitely pull the trigger. You think
Nick I think Nick could pull the trigger. Thoughts?
I was asking QTCinderella, but you know what? I'll ask you guys
in chat. I I was read- I was reading something. Sorry. I literally
wasn't paying attention to what you're saying. Uh I said he's
got like an Elliot Rodger aura about him. I I don't doubt that
xQc thought he could get shot. I feel like Nick could pull the
trigger. his kid That kid would be an insane incel. Asian father,
white mother,
so much self-hate it's unreal. Asian cuck father that like Yeah,
he'll want to [__] his mom 100%.
He will want to [__] his dad. It will be actually
It will be Dude, he'll be
That's right. It's over. I I'm Amouranth's a cool friend, but
um dates, never again.
Why? Why? Why was this made? Why That I don't even think this
works.
I don't I I don't Talk about it. Anyway, that's my story of the
day. Oh, sure sure. That's it. Take my welcome to the jungle
virginity. Jesus. I don't know what this is. Dates And you started
calling me on You had me go on Tinder dates that I didn't want
to go on. Nice teacher. karaoke bar a lot.
That is no.
You were wanting to open a relationship.
No, that
No, I did not.
We're literally not lying.
I did not.
these men can't even find that would make us money of such acts
that you were claiming right now. Yet you're saying I would do
it off stream for no money?
Correct. I did not do that.
these men can't even find that Okay, maybe I will sleep with
Aaron. Did we Did we say that? That is not No. You never asked
that? No, I did not. But I'm just waiting for XQC to say something.
Oh, okay. We're going to lie to your chat now. Okay. We're literally
not lying. And you didn't give him a hand job in the parking
lot. I did not.
Together, you giving him a hand job in the parking lot in Chinatown.
These men can't even find that party. OH, MY GOD. CUZ PORN STARS
NEVER HAVE SEX OFF You have me going Um chat, yeah, this is what
signing one kick deal does to people aware.
I didn't want to play I didn't want to go on. Chat, he wanted
he wanted to heard it on dates.
That she didn't want to go on I don't Chat, what does that mean,
chat? Chat, what does that mean? Chat, is that no disrespect?
Cuz I don't know this person. I'm not going to Cuz he likes 100%
betting the CLMs here. That's [__] up. I don't I
don't like fire shots at people but I hate people for no reason.
Is this like Hold on. Is it like a like a thing or not? That's
[__] up, dude. Nick is in denial but his true nature
is very unfortunate. You hate to see it. People who hate themselves,
self-hating like that. Hold on. Quick clip. What is this? Never
SWAT us. [__] is this? There's audio on it. Never
SWAT us. The person who SWAT us is a
Nice. Stay public. Wait, they definitely are in a massive fight
again. She is like been weeping while they worked out. This This
is 7 minutes ago. Oh boy.
Thanks. He said it.
Now it looks LIKE I MADE YOU SAY IT. YEAH. Uh yeah, obviously.
You need to stop, Nick. I'm trying to work out. Please leave
me alone so I can work out. Let's talk.
We did.
Let's Now it's all good. That's all good. Put facing the the
wall or something. Why don't you mute the stream so we can
talk a little bit, okay, sweetheart? It was muted. Jesus Christ.
All right. Well, we're not very far from that. However, hold
on. Yo, I need 10 hours 19 whatever. Let's keep going. And then
in addition I need to see the arc of the story. So we have to
go from Olive Garden to the gym, okay? What does she need like
30 minutes after eating before she goes to the gym?
All right. It's broader. It wasn't just kind of everything. So
then just the point is that So that Okay, I remember now. So
if you It's okay. You don't have to answer it. I get it. If I'm
going to be eat If I If I'm monetizing on social media at all,
you want me to be on a specific workout schedule or else my animal
time is limited. Is it that it's so hard? It's not hard. It's
just the fact that you would require that is kind of crazy to
me. But maybe it's just cuz I'm unrealistic.
Oh my god, he's so controlling. Like what an [__]
Ice cream for breakfast, lunch, and dinner instead of a balanced
meal and maybe a little ice cream at the end of the day. It's
not not really. Horse riding is still a form of exercise. No,
I know it is but like I'm just saying, you know, unless you're
saying that to you the working out and looking good is not important.
Wait.
How did nobody link me this? I see all I see a bunch of my chatters
in her chat right now. How did nobody link me this? You guys,
I had to go see this by
I mean like not not doing like the grind. Like kick country having
a farm I relevant I don't care about my relevance. I don't care
about that. That's more what it is. What if I wanted to social
media but I don't care about my relevancy as an attractive
attraction based streamer. I just wanted to do that. Do you have
an OnlyFans? Do you have anything like OnlyFans? People can still
pay for it. Well, then no. Then it still matters. Here's my thought
process on this, okay? Why? What's the laugh? It just sounds
exhausting. Amouranth's going to get by on her winning personality.
Let's go. It's a choice that you get to make, right? But it's
like this, right? Like I feel like if you're going to do something
like look, it's different if you're like starting right now.
Okay. I don't want to sound like an
could you imagine if I get Amouranth to come on streams with
Kelly who like hates Oh my god. That'd be awesome. That would
be awesome. Oh my god. Amazing content. There's no reason she'd
want to do it but like Oh my god.
And let's be honest here. OnlyFans is Let me ask you this. The
content you make on OnlyFans if you didn't get paid for it, would
you still make it? No. Okay. And you know, so obviously it's
not just that you get paid it's that you get paid an amount that
you think is worth the effort, I just think it's silly to keep
having, you know, cuz like you know, it takes a lot of supply
chain to do the thing. Even if you go to AI, it still takes Did
she almost turn your stream on or did I dream that? Her Discord
account, she's still got a notable in the server. She's still
in the server right now. Yeah. Yeah, I think Hold on. Maybe this
Maybe this changed. Maybe it changed. Hold on. x.com/amouranth
She definitely followed me at some
Nope, she's still following. Based. I really should have thought
more before just going to her for [__] but
thank god there's nothing to do with us unfortunately there.
You're hoping to edit or compile or deliver content. What if
I just wanted it to be you know, I want to work out when I work
out. I want to play horses go horse riding when I want to go
horse riding. What's wrong with that? You're the breadwinner
anyway at this point, Mr. Well, if I'm the breadwinner then yeah,
it doesn't matter. It's okay.
Yeah, I mean like my my whole point is that How many jobs can
you handle then? Cuz you're going to need a lot of them to be
the breadwinner. My point is just that like if we're going to
Cuz like the just even to our relationship, would you agree that
there's a cost to you doing OnlyFans? It's going to be a big
cost. I'm not the one who started the OnlyFans. It's not like
I one day was like, "Oh, I want to do OnlyFans. It's kind of
like a grand adventure." But like there has been strain historically.
Okay, but if there's strain, I can stop right now. I don't care.
Well, no, that's that's my point. I'm saying if we're going to
keep doing it, then You're okay with stopping the income flow?
If you are. Like that's a you question.
All right, we'll keep that in mind. No, absolutely. Like Okay,
you're saying that like in a way
when have I ever not been okay with it? I don't know. It just
it feels like if you're trying to like venture out to be a content
creator, I don't know if you think you're going to be monetizing
that much at first. Well, it would obviously be an advantage
if I was becoming an influencer and you still monetize on OnlyFans.
That would be the best of both worlds probably. But you know,
again, if we were going to do it that way, you know, you might
not have to stream all that much if you don't want to. But then
the workout schedule and the you know, all of that. I don't know
why Nick thinks he can be an influencer. I actually don't get
it.
don't get it at all. Until AI gets good enough for it, it doesn't
matter at all. Right, but also
here's the thing, right? In my opinion, let's say AI is good
enough, right? It's Jesus.
Jesus. Like [__] Carrie. Still not quite what you
want unless you're saying She's like putting her hatred for Nick
into the camera right now. That's so good. Okay, your stream
is an AI you. Then yeah, sure. Well, they don't need to be streamed
convincingly in order to have like 30-second videos be convincing.
That's the thing though. If they compared you on your stream
and it looks dramatically different in terms of especially fitness
level, that's going to be problematic because then Well, my fitness
level doesn't have to change me not have a requirement to see
my horses. Oh, you think I'm going to stop working out so I don't
work? I just don't want to certain like the work three times
a week. If not, no horses. Like that sucks. Like I should be
able to dictate my own fitness. I've never been like fat. You
got fat. I've never been fat in my life. I think I can handle
myself. You've also never been hyperfit.
I don't need to be. I'm happy with my body. Well, the goal We
had goals about that at one point in the past. You had goals.
I never cared. She's never been like Wait. What Hold on. What
does he mean by hyperfit? I feel like she had a pretty
She had like a pretty defined stomach at one point. What does
he mean by hyperfit? the way that I am.
You created your own workout regimen. I never input in any of
that. I wouldn't have one if you didn't want me to have That
is not true again. Are you Not like a schedule I need to work
out three times in order to see my horse. That was all you. Okay,
I don't have fitness goals. I just like to be healthy and stay
strong. I don't have like a certain like thing that I'm trying
to reach. I don't It's not that serious to me. Historically,
we have a home gym because you wanted one. Yeah, because I like
to work out. I don't want a certain I don't have a certain goal
that I'm trying to achieve. I'm just trying to be strong and
healthy. I don't have like a certain physique that I'm trying
to craft, you know? Like a certain amount of time that I need
to do. Well, the thing is like I if you're going to monetize
through OnlyFans, I think it makes sense. If not, then sure,
whatever. Okay. Fair enough. Yeah, just cuz I I still think OnlyFans
has a relational cost. And so obviously there's probably a threshold
of earnings that make that worthwhile versus not worthwhile.
It's everything there, right? Like even like someone who is a
waitress, let's say you go to this high-end restaurant where
you get huge tips. But you know, guys like to hit on you at that
restaurant. And that girl's dating or or married to someone else.
Obviously like there's a discussion you have there, right? Which
is like
how much does that matter if she's Anonymous just tipped $5.
I will pay for Nick's OnlyFans. Waiting for that link. Anonymous
just tipped $5. I will pay for Nick's OnlyFans. Waiting for that
sugar daddy link drop, Plaza.
Dr. Phil just tipped $1. That's so What are you going to Dr.
Phil just tipped Dude, they're
$1. That's so interesting. I don't know why I didn't know to
elaborate. But yeah, I I We'll see what happens but I really
mean it though. Like when Anonymous just tipped $10. Gaslighting
manipulative e dollar dollar hat. Anonymous just tipped $10.
Gaslighting manipulative e dollar dollar hat thinks he owns you.
He does own me. What do you mean? Tell me I'm a good girl. But
yeah, when has me working super hard and you chilling ever been
a problem for us? Never. Exactly. So why would you be so pressed?
Just because I just don't know if you working hard is going to
be the result you think it's going to be. If it isn't, I will
go quietly into the night.
What What else would I do? I don't know. You're crazy.
What you should actually be scared about is if both of us have
all Yeah, I don't want to read too much into that. That didn't
feel comfortable. Like touch here and she kind of like coils
up. What you should actually be scared about
Cuz he kind of just came down purely on there, didn't he? if
both of us have all of free time Oh. Oh. Because that is the
only scenario we have not experienced
That's true. Everything else is known. But but I thought you
said that's what we're looking forward to. Well, yeah, that's
why it's so it's like this, right? Um we've been in a car for
10 years on a road trip with the promise of driving from Texas
to Tokyo Disney. That's why it took so long. We got to find a
ship and drive our car on a ship and we spent 8 years on ferry.
Right. You're about to get there. Obviously you have I'm not
about to cuz it sounds like I'm about to get to the point where
you're working all the time and I'm not again. It doesn't sound
like we're getting into the point where neither of us are working
and we get to enjoy what we built. Well, hear me out. Like even
me being a streamer, the guy model streaming is not the girl
I think we talked about this earlier, but it's like 2 3 hours
a day, 5 6 days a week, done. Is that really that impactful?
I don't know. We'll find out. Dude, what girl streamer streams
18 hours a day? What are you talking about? How is she following
the girl model?
The girl model is more relaxed than the guy model. What is he
talking about? That guy model he described is like what Mizkif
does now that he's like streamer royalty. Every other streamer
actually puts in hours. I mean yeah, we can always adjust, but
but the idea is this is that we have experienced me working and
you not. We've also experienced both of us working, right? Mhm.
The only thing we haven't experienced is both of us not having
to work at all. scared about that with me? not scared about that.
I'm just I'm just joking kind of. I'm saying that like it's the
unknown unknown, right? Like no, obviously it's like that's that's
my analogy. It's like 10 years you've been trying to drive towards
this theme park and finally you're in the parking lot and you're
you know getting ready to get out of your car and go in. Obviously
you have all these, you know, aspirations and hopes that you
know, they'll be as good as you, you know, Chat says you just
pretend to work. They think you just shop all day. Oh.
Guys, for 10 years we've confounded every other e-girl because
they thought Amouranth just was a superhuman
person who streamed 12 hours a day Dr. Phil just tipped $1. and
worked on social media and planned out content and did Dr. Phil
just tipped $1. Fascinating. Makes you get higher than normal
for minimum. But uh anyways, it it's been an absolute edge. Like
I have no idea what you guys think why you think it hasn't been.
Like
Okay, Amouranth's retirement plan, okay? I have it right now,
all right? We need architect streams, okay? No working out. Just
Olive Garden slop all day, okay? Feeding Amouranth to the point
where and there's like stretch goals. You you literally pay money
to feed her like more biscuits and stuff. My god, the money they
could make. Could you imagine? Now, what you could say
I WOULD PAY I WOULD PAY money to watch Amouranth eat different
stuff, okay? And Wait, just watching her like literally watching
the camera and just It was COMPELLING CONTENT. I DON'T think
the chat moves faster. this not sound weird as hell right now.
You look I don't think the chat has Okay, I can make it sound
weird, but I don't think the chat's ever moved faster than that
moment where we were watching her eat that bucket of slop, okay?
I've I It's It hasn't. It was compelling content for some reason.
It was horrifying and enchanting at the same time, okay? Is that
Uh-huh.
Is the edge worth more than
50% which is essentially what I get? I would argue it is because
the best agencies charge 20 to 30. And generally 30. Um that
leaves 20%, but those agencies only help you with your laugh.
They don't help you with your social. They don't help you with
planning ideas. They don't help you with, you know, courting
press.
And that's just 20% which literally is Dr. Phil just tipped $1.
Please, go on. I'm going to go do a set. Dr. Phil just tipped
$1.
He's talking about this. He's like, all right, I'm going to go
work out. Bye. go on. Oh, thank god. Take him. Anonymous just
tipped $2.
You have lost all my respect. Okay, thank you. You know what?
I've get But I've gained $2. Your respect was worth $0. Your
$2 donation is worth $2. Thank you. I'll trade that every time.
My horse needs to listen to this conversation, so I got to go
work out. Of course you'd rather ride your horses than listen
to me. Don't tell me this one inch stuff. What the I don't want
to know about penis [__] you rather have a 3-inch
or a 9-inch It's very obvious.
I think the 3 inches is actually better than 9 inches to be honest,
but 6 inches is probably the ideal. Well, I have bad news for
you because I think your horse is more well-endowed. Well, I'm
not talking about my I mean, to be fair, she said that pretty
convincingly. I think their entire medic uh marriage is predicated
on her making that sound believable, so
Nasty. Wait, do you know who has a 9-inch penis? What the No.
My turn to say what the [__] I thought we were on
the same page. You're so annoying. Chat, she told me that every
time she says I'm annoying on stream, it's actually not a bit.
It's not. And he doesn't believe me It's a good bit. I love the
acting. Oh, we staged the other day, holy Oh, yeah. God, good.
That was great, right? Uh-huh. And y'all calling me abuser just
like we planned. Oh, it's ugly. I'm going to go cross the room.
Okay.
And I'm just following. I'm not going to give him a mic. I'm
a shadow. Get here. Dude.
Dude. Oh, this is so Actually, what the uh is she Is she actually
starts crying? She's weird as hell, okay? And no and no because
no one broke up.
[__] look at the move. All right, so you're cool
with me being on red pill [__] I don't care. Okay.
You want to make yourself an ass hat, go for it. Let me tell
you this stuff. The moment you start caring, let me know. I mean,
I do care, but you don't care that I care, so I guess I don't
care. Okay, we can talk about it later. How about that? All right.
Sure. Dude, I feel like I could If I had any faith that any of
the socials I have Amouranth on, I was actually talk going to
be talking to her, I'd just send like, hey, watch my coverage.
You should come on my stream. I feel like she'd be like I feel
like it could happen.
Um once you get in there and you're settled, I'm going to move
Big O Big O is going to join me because Big O is literally more
consistent streamer than That's true. He starts streaming twice
Why don't you try reaching out to him and try to get him on?
Come on. Uh
cuz he's not really the talent. And he could be fun to have on
different
But you could have both Okay, here's here's the pitch, okay?
Go to this guy. Say you do like a So like um loose political
debate panel show that, you know, you've you've heard him on
Amouranth's stream. He thinks that you think uh he's I don't
know. He's a really smart guy. He's got some real great insights.
He'd do really well on the show.
He'd do really well on the show. But uh he should bring he should
bring Amouranth cuz we think uh they they play off each other
well. We think uh he's a great straight man to how crazy she
is. And then get Say say that to
And he'll come on with a I guarantee, okay? Uh-huh. Uh-huh. It's
a You call her daughter, then you keep calling her he he. What's
that it? God. It's a lovely transition. She never transitioned.
You just didn't know her gender. My little boy
Well, you guys tell her to start being more feminine, too, so
you don't get confused. Chill. What did I say to you? Earlier
today you told me to start to be more feminine when you were
nagging me off stream. Well, it's cuz like uh Be more feminine.
In what In other words, be more submissive and stop retaliating.
Just go get your bird.
She said you're so goddamn aggressive. Jesus Christ. Cold out
in Texas. Can you move it right now if you want so you don't
forget? Put him in a thing. Move him right now. Yeah, right now.
Okay, so put him on the stairs or in his
Or wherever you want to put him. Her. Anonymous just tipped $1.
The thought of divorcing and getting less than 50%
$1. The thought of divorcing and getting less than 50% with the
drop in his status is what he loops on in all of his rants. He's
honest at least. I'm sure the assets are the biggest concerns.
It checks out. Okay, 10 hours 35. I'm going to refresh this so
we don't get cut off. But go back before the stream ended. What?
It's fine. 10 hours 35 minutes.
Where we were. Wait, what? My carrier Cut out here apparently.
Yep. It's back. Guys, we're separating them. We're separating
mom and dad from the babies. The babies need to fledge. They
need to fend for themselves even though there's no one on the
room that will pick them. I feel like um you ever seen Smile,
Queen Man? Oh. Okay, it's a horror movie and like the person
in like one of the opening sequences, person gets like a shard
of glass while smiling and like slowly does themself in, okay?
Uh like like just slices I don't want I'm on Twitch still, so
I'm being a little careful. I feel like that's what we're about
to witness here at some point. Like that Amouranth's just going
to start like doing something is I It's like dude,
the constant staring into the camera right now. Mom and Dad hate
being picked Specifically Dad. Aw. They're also cute right now
though. You want to see? I've seen them. Just go in there before
sitting on the same plate. Yeah.
What they do? Mom and Dad.
But Baymax kind of wants her part-time boyfriend back. Mhm. Would
you ever share a guy? If I didn't like him, maybe. [__]
So if you ever let me [__] spray cuz you don't That's
right. But you actually like me now? No, cuz you want to stop
lying thinking I'm divorced. Maybe not like you enough so you
can have a threesome or like have another girl on the side. I
didn't know that was an option. No. Y'all, at least currently
I'm way too goddamn bougie to be doing that. No.
The baby with the weird leg is able to stand, but No, hold on.
Go away, Nick. No, don't go away, Nick. Nick is literally what's
making this compelling. Have you guys watched Never mind. We're
not putting that on on tape right now. Never mind. Oh, this is
cut out. We watched his interview with Pearl. We watched a little
bit of it. It was incredibly boring. Uh maybe I'll start skipping
forward to see when this cuts back in. Okay. Well, but I mentioned
it to you, but I guess you weren't interested which is fine cuz
obviously you what works for you, right? Yeah. Oh, [__]
so glad they decided to start talking in the room with the birds.
Thank god. Guys, guys, guys, guys, it's okay. It's okay. Guys,
you're safe. Nothing's going to happen. You're going back to
your old home. With other birds that you like.
Dude, I will say it's incredibly weird to like love birds and
not like dogs, okay? That's That's bizarre. I don't know what
the deal is.
The queen with the Q guy just said that is his food. That's his
food, guys. He's Chinese. This is the soup This is the soup room,
okay?
What? The the stuff. Or I was just in the gym already. We just
got it out to use it. I don't know what the stream is scuffing.
Yeah, I didn't use your account for anything. I just made new
Okay. Is she like practicing looking horrified into the camera?
Like she she looks I I can't tell if this is acting or what now
cuz
cuz she's like she's actually like practicing or like looking
at the camera looking like she's about to cry and then she gets
back inside when the lights are on and she's like fine. I did
have them but not previously. Yeah. I felt That is interesting.
I don't know what You think so?
I I don't understand it cuz like it feels different than some
of the other stuff. That's all. I did have a weird thing too
like cuz like the first couple days I kept being
Like really bad. And he did something I don't know for what,
but it was like fine. It was like some It might just be talking
out my ass right now, but I should be like setting your stream
key or some [__] Hey, look who it is. Dude, she was
literally like about to start crying right there. She is crying.
She is, right? She's showing you off camera now. She's off camera
now. That was her I saw it. I could see
that one where she started crying right
And now she's sitting with her face off camera cuz she doesn't
want to cry on camera. just tipped $1. You see she is upset.
Why can't you just let her have space? Your date just tipped
$1.
You see she is upset. Why can't you just let her have space,
psycho?
She's literally about to get in the panic room right now. Dude,
this is like somebody pointed out earlier. It is like an episode
of Black Mirror, isn't it? Like this person who's an influencer
with all of this money and it's just like the the the like life
is falling apart. She's got all these possessions and just like
empty. I don't know. It's just sad that like I see these horses
more than my real ones. It sucks.
It's just sad that like I see these horses more than my real
ones. Hold on. I'm so sorry. So, it's a meme contest. It's not
my fault. Oh, whoops. That's the wrong channel. What's up? Babe,
what's Are you okay?
Nothing. Fine. Uh what? Oh, what? miss my little pony. What?
You miss your horses? Yeah. Well, why is that you're so funny?
I don't know. It just doesn't feel like enough, but it's fine.
I'll be okay. What are you doing? Only a month and then I get
to see them all the time, right? Here, mute it real fast. Dude,
She uh she kind of looks like the Snapchat filter. Like I could
I'm so I'm so sorry, Amouranth. It's [__] up. Uh
not that one. kidding, man. Just making a joke out of it. You're
a patient man. I just want to work out. Uh-huh. Nobody showed
that clip, okay? It's okay. I was just going to go work out.
I'm glad your birds are back. True. Salvation. Salvation.
Nick, she she's just she's playing hard to get. Nick, go to her
now. Nick, where are you? Nick, SHE NEEDS A ROCK. NICK, YEAH,
the audio's muted on their end. That's their They're muted, not
me. No, it's it She muted her stream. If By the way, if I don't
laugh at this, it's going to be be very awkward if I just sit
here like pensive, okay? You can either laugh or you can feel
like you want to hurt yourself for being such a horrible person,
okay? I choose to laugh. Dude, he's right on her tail. I might
start skipping forward until we get audio again. He won't follow
you Work out. Hold on.
Got to see what this is. Anonymous just tipped $1. Asked to go
sit in the security car with guard for a few minutes. He won't
follow you there. Work out later. Wow.
Had music or something? Sure, hold on. Never swat us. The person
who No, I was too late. I was too late. It's It literally could
have worked perfectly for so much of this stream. Okay, hold
on. We're going back. Too bad. It is the time for the clip. This
was the clip.
Never swat us. The person who swat us is a Not safe. [__]
that. It looks like a major safety. Thanks. Thanks. Put it down.
You need to stop, Nick. I'm trying to work out. Please leave
me alone so I can work out. Let's
We did. You don't have to work out anymore for the [__]
horses. Let's talk. Let's use that time to Her facing that wall
or something. Anonymous just tipped $1. Go sit with the guard.
He won't harass you there. I'll start skipping through a little
bit. Gone through a minute 30. Still no sound. 2 minutes.
2:30. Still no sound. 3 minutes 30. Still no sound. Nick is live
with Amouranth's head in a cooking pot. Obviously. Little Justin
Y throwback for anybody who was here for that. The first stream
Qwiman
and I ever did for a long period together. Reading that guy's
manifesto. spamming my right arrow now trying to go through this.
They're still off stream right now. The lights went out. Oh,
they walked out of here, right? They probably have motion lights.
I don't know if they come back. Skipping through. Skipping through.
Skipping through.
Bro, really?
Whoa. We got Amouranth back. Whoa. Motion? Ammo? Alive? Shockingly.
Where is she? She's walked in. He's wearing her skin. Okay. I
don't want to skip forward too much more cuz I know she's there.
Yeah. All right. We'll probably skip back over to Nick in just
a second. There's no way she actually works out, right?
Oh, she she actually
Dude, that's crazy.
That's pretty loud, though.
Look, Nick Nick didn't win here, okay? If Nick won, she'd be
wearing like a bikini while doing this, okay? Amouranth won.
She's wearing a sweater. She's wearing some baggy pants, okay?
We're actually good.
Dude, imagine she just did this like the like she's a zombie
just this exercise for like 20 minutes straight until she just
like passed out from loss of blood flow to her. She's like just
like in a trance like only doing this over and over again.
Okay, this is 11:32. This is where we stopped. I think it's over,
right? Yeah, 11:32. That's where we tuned in.
Just her working out. Andrew Tate just tipped one buck. Caitlyn,
I can't do anything to help you like this. That goes hard. This
could be like This goes pretty hard.
of anything giving in to his demands. You need a lawyer ASAP.
Is recording Amouranth? It's just her It's her camera sitting
there. Dude, does she do anything but like abs and like accessories?
She's like, yeah, I don't do back. I don't do I don't do legs.
I don't do arms. I just do abs and random accessory lifts, okay?
Where is Nick? I believe Nick has gone live at approximately
this
Watch a little bit towards the end of her but she's basically
done. She's going to work out a little bit. This gym would be
sick, though.
That's a crazy equipped gym. Okay, at this point, why wouldn't
she just like start inviting I maybe she just doesn't have that
many friends because of her and Nick's relationship or something.
I don't know. Like why wouldn't she just start inviting your
friends to live with you and [__]
Yeah, I got it. I know Nick's live.
Like I I just start inviting friends to come live with me. Get
a like a whole gym, a whole complex and [__]
Would live in that sty? Bro, for free rent, you wouldn't go clean
up that sty? Just if you could just live there and have like
a full gym and all this [__]
Is that a guy in the background? That is a mannequin, 100%.
Okay. Well, this is the end of her stream right here. It looks
like. Yeah, this is just it.
I can't tell if she disconnects or what. And she's she's live
again now. Is she just live again now? Yeah. Oh, she switched
over to Amouranth.
Stop. Stop. Hold on. I have to go back to see it. What was the
dono? Did it go back far enough? I didn't go back far enough.
Hold on. I don't want to miss that dono.
Okay, stop. Stop. Stop. Do not be crazy in her chat, okay? Don't
do it. I I skipped I just skipped past it again, didn't I? Hold
on. The dogs are barking. Okay. My god.
I'm getting annoyed, okay? JSTL kid just tipped $1.
Hi Amaranth, my friend Kelly Jean has pent-up anger towards you.
I'd love to get you guys in a call to
I'd love to get you guys in a call to figure it out. You guys
are [__] embarrassing. That's what you guys are.
You actually can't embarrass me. Actually embarrassing. you got
to receive your emotions fast. I called him out on that earlier,
like afterwards, and he told me, allegedly, Actually just that
was being Totally [__] embarrassing. Hold on. We're
going to pull up Nick. I'm not that stupid, at least, okay? Not
that stupid
We passed, dude. This is a dog [__] setup. I don't
know if this this is not the best optimal setup, but you know,
we are doing what we do. Well, it's I feel like I have um Oh,
[__] I closed the wrong window. Uh I feel like I
do a lot of self-deprecating humor, and sometimes I assume that
other people are okay with it, too. But they're not. They really
are not. Okay. Okay, let's see if I can do this thing. I didn't
I didn't see the pigeon, but I did definitely heard it right
there. It's cooing into the mic. I'm trying to figure out figure
out briefly how I can add someone as a mod, even though I've
already done this once. This is cool. Okay, cool. I mean, I'll
take it. I wish I could hear myself.
Is she worth over 100 million? I don't think they're worth 100
million. They're probably worth a lot, like 50 plus, but I don't
I don't know about 100 yet. Listen, we'll fix I guess if they
invested super heavily with their money,
from the time they started making it,
okay? Yeah, but Baygon's just like uh
Oh, what up? Fan page. I will tell you why, okay? I made her
cry. In my defense, I'm an idiot. No, like um basically it was
just that a couple months ago, uh she wanted me to help with
Give me 2 seconds. I'll be right called Furry Fridays, which
is what she
does on Fridays, where she streams animal for me. Actually, I
shouldn't say that. Don't clip that. Basically, we have to wake
up at the crack of dawn, 8:00 a.m., to get ready to go to the
barn. Waking up early is tough for me, okay? I haven't done it
in years, but
and so my my my thing was just like, "Okay, we're going to do
Furry Fridays, and then I'd like it if we also, you know, just
committed to a workout routine,
and stated that, right?" And so that was the kind of agreement.
But I guess she doesn't like that anymore, and so she's been,
you know, kind of pushing back on it. But like you saw the thing
earlier when she I was on her stream, she's like,
"Why do we have to do that?" And it's like, for me, I'm a dude.
Don't ask me why if you don't want a reason. Just tell me you
want something
You get what I'm saying? Like I get real Socratic when you start
saying like,
you know, it's like if you said like um if you're in a store
and you go like, you know, "Why does the candy bar cost $2?"
It's like I'm going to tell you why it costs $2.
If you ask me if you can have a candy bar, well, you know, I'll
decide whether you can have it, right? Like I'm I'm very straightforward
and blunt. And I just kind of Yeah, I miscue a bunch. It's weird
because, honestly, Yo, I'm traveling. Just dropped a new rap
as much as you can in regular situations. It's just with her
that I
You know? Oh, dude, it has to be LaFerrari, man. Has to be LaFerrari.
I like the 918,
but are you kidding me? The LaFerrari is like beautiful. I can't
I can't spell it. She is beautiful.
You guys missed it, but I'm somewhat confident we'll be invited
Are you okay, Baygon? I'm somewhat confident we'll be invited
But um last year, I streamed I don't care about this guy's stream.
Vladimir Putin just tipped $1. We declare a special military
operation on Nick. He'll be de-Am Vladimir Putin just tipped
$1. We declare a special military operation on
He'll be de-Am erantified and sent back to Vietnam. The Houston
PD is about to occupy their compound, okay? They get so many
calls.
It'll be Okay, well, at least Nick is
Is it lost in Oh, you know, there's literally three uh massage
like there's like three massages even, like cuz they set up like
a mobile spa. It's like the most pampered [__] in
the world, but obviously, you know, it's 2 million a year. And
it's like 50 guys paying 2 million a year. So, of course, right?
And so, me invited, even though we neither are a member nor have
paid the 2 million.
What is he talking about? I have no [__] idea. $1.
Glug glug glug Glug glug glug Green man with a huge just tipped
$1. Glug glug glug glug glug glug glug glug glug glug glug What
the [__] up on that.
[__] up when they did that from our stream, to tell
you the truth. They're so tolerant of that. What the
That's weird. And we got invited as a guest of uh Who are the
one Freeze? Baygon, press him. Is the camera frozen? Wait, what
the [__] does that even mean? Oh, did I not reset
any of the meters from when we added to ours? I did not. Whatever.
Wait, someone said something very
You have lost any credibility you could possibly have when I
saw you selling my table stream.
Are you saying Carrot Top is Kate? Is that what you're saying?
thing I can do. I teach that pug things he couldn't forget. Thanks,
Peter.
Okay. He smokes around I mean, you know, I like you. Criticizing
me won't make it a joke,